[Music]
what's up baby this is another episode
of congratulations
all right man [ __ ] let's get right
into it
dude hot take coming in june
and july shouldn't be back to back they
should rename those [ __ ] months
period
i always say june instead of july and
july instead of june it's like the
name's dave and dan
pick one name and have every dan or dave
be dan or dave
not [ __ ] you know what i'm talking
about i guys say june instead of july
say july june
and i get my [ __ ] mixed up man and
people will be like hey you're supposed
to be here and i'll be like what we said
july 9th and he said no
[ __ ] june 9th i look back sure enough
june 9th and i [ __ ] it all up for the
month anyway
that's not my fault yo you got months
like [ __ ] november and [ __ ]
in there mix it up dude mix it the [ __ ]
up
mix it the frig up i'm mormon mix it the
frig up dude
july and june are together oh really
they weren't marching may together dude
they're not
they got april in between them we talk
about the hard
hitting issues we talk about
the hard hitting issues welcome to npr
june and july should not be
together let's take our first caller dan
dan how are you
hey it's actually dave my bad
thinking if you'd like to make a call
please hang up and try again
[Music]
c
[Laughter]
if you're in the 80s you know what's up
dude that's what used to happen when you
leave the [ __ ] phone off the hook
they shouldn't annoy you like that in
the back in the 80s dude
um they shouldn't have annoyed you when
your phone's off the hook that should
have been that ass no
no phone should have been [ __ ] bang
bang bang bang bang
punk you ever do that you ever across
the room ping pang
pang pang then you got to get up what if
you just wanted to leave the phone
there you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up dude
um
anyway june and july spread it out put
[ __ ] november in between it it should
go
january february march april may
june november july oh
that's the other thing too september
october november
december you're gonna have all the ember
[ __ ] months together [ __ ] off dude
who made that [ __ ] up greeks probably
way back when
yeah they did dude who made up the
calendar it was [ __ ] some greek
guy who only covered his shoulder and
nothing else
uh anyway dude it doesn't matter who
made it whoever did it oh
[ __ ] what was the guy i was watching
all those shows some guy it doesn't
matter dude
but we're still trying to figure it out
in the back of our heads even though
we're going to move on to something else
ah yes dude
um that's yeah that's that's how it is
that's how it is
i think also i was talking about this is
another thing
i was talking about hot actors
like brad pitt and um
who else is [ __ ] hot like chris well
there's another one that
puts the theory on its ass christian
bale
women can be really good at acting and
really really
beautiful hot dudes are usually
[ __ ] terrible at acting usually but
there are exceptions christian bale
brad pitt is a very good
actor super hot i actually think brad
pitt
is a better actor than he is hot because
i think that
he's a bit hot guy
which deducts points christian bale
very very handsome very attractive and
sexy
but not [ __ ]
model brad pitt kind of guy you know
what i mean
not [ __ ] aqua di giorgio hot in the
80s
laying by a pool like this
kind of kind of hot that's that brad
pitt [ __ ] george clooney
super good looking pretty damn good
actor
but when you talk about like julia
roberts beautiful
but also doing dry heaving type acting
where you're like oh she found her
[ __ ] daughter in a dumpster all day
and she's like
you know what i mean you're like god
damn dude
is there real daughter in there
i mean how many women are good heather
graham kills it dude
kills it i think she's amazing dude
she's so good
and um who but who else though there's
other [ __ ] beautiful women
that are so good at acting they don't
get the props at the [ __ ]
male or female you don't get the props
that the uglies get you don't get the
props that the uglies get you don't
philip seymour hoffman bam the guy from
[ __ ]
big fat liar who did the voice over to
the sons of sam
paul giamatti bam he gets the credit
brad pitt could act his ass off and do a
paul giamatti type dry heave acting
brad pitt could be [ __ ]
paul giamatti level style type acting
in [ __ ] king speech just i i like lie
and people will be like next colin firth
want to [ __ ] oscar
because he's pretty okay kind of
handsome
if he was brad pitt level just i like
he wouldn't even got nominated he would
have got snubbed city dude snub city for
[ __ ] colin firth
drinking coffee for those watching for
those listening smoking a bong
so anyway dude i know about my bang [ __ ]
i know about bong
um i know about bong
uh yeah so who else puts that [ __ ] right
and then my girl was like
you know who [ __ ] breaks this you
know who shatters the stereotype that
hot guys can't ask
and i said who and she was like
tom [ __ ] hardy and i was like
he's he's a damn good actor and he's
pretty [ __ ]
sexy but i have a feeling tom hardy is
five nine
just gonna put that out there don't know
how tall he is
um also there's the level of acting
that christian bale can do daniel de
lulu can do
[ __ ] robert de niro can do
al pacichi these guys all do it and
[ __ ] kill it
al pacino could oh dude if he was in
king's speech they would give him two
oscars
oh r-i-i-i-i
o-i-i-i-i-i
they make good choices dude de niro
makes good choices
these guys are good you know who you
know who [ __ ] ripped
and let me just actually tell you right
now
i had no idea this guy was a good actor
as a matter of fact before this
movie that i saw which was [ __ ]
terrible
and i could say that now i could talk
about what movies are bad and what
movies are good now because i'll never
be in any movies
but um this guy was so good
in this movie i thought he was a bad
actor because he was handsome
but this guy was the only good thing
about this movie is it
[ __ ] king kong vs godzilla or
godzilla vs king kong i don't know what
it was called
there was an old one called one of the
ways and then the new one is called
the other way i think this one's called
godzilla versus king kong
and the one in like the 40s was king
kong vs godzilla
i don't know why they didn't just
[ __ ] why did you change it you know
the sars guard guy i don't know
what his first name is because i think
there's another
actor that's last name is tsar's guard
sarsguard must be like the dutch
smith or whatever the [ __ ] swedish smith
it's got two a's and a [ __ ] k in it a
2k it's weird it's
a weird last name skarsgard and um
that guy is so good in the hong kong
movie
because he is so he i didn't know he
could do character [ __ ]
it was like tom cruise when he played
the [ __ ] guy in uh
tropical thunder i almost said jungle
fever
um and uh
tropical thunder uh uh when tom cruise
came in and did the dancing it was the
fat bald guy
but what's his name [ __ ] skarsgard is
it peter
alexander dude
alexander skarsgard too many syllables
hello syllables for sale alexander
skarsgard was like i'll have 12.
and uh and he did a character acting in
that movie and he was
so good now let me tell you another
thing that movie
made no sense i thought when i was
watching a movie i was like oh i'm a
dumb [ __ ] idiot i can't understand
king kong
or godzilla versus king kong
or if i was japanese i call it godzilla
which is weird how sometimes japanese
guys say sneak in english words but kind
of make it a little japanese [ __ ]
oh godzilla well actually godzilla is
japanese so
whatever the [ __ ] but you know what i
mean
and um he's in that movie and he's good
and that movie has
900 leads why is everybody in that movie
a main character dude so
many people in that main character in
that movie oops got a tumor so many
people in that movie
are leads in are the lead
they've got [ __ ] so many people in
that movie by the way
dude first of all let me go back to this
i thought the movie was not going to
make any i
i thought it was dumb i was like this is
am i a dumb oh i'm a dumb [ __ ] idiot
you ever watch a movie like okay i'm a
dumb [ __ ] here this is king kong i
should get it this is godzilla versus
king kong i should get it watch the
movie all of a sudden
i feel like okay i'm a dumb and
then i text my friends during the
[ __ ] godzilla versus king kong am i a
dumb [ __ ] idiot
and my friend said no don't worry that
movie [ __ ] makes no sense
and i was like really then i was like
what's this robot godzilla and he texts
back
i don't know and i said well who's the
scientist that created it and why did he
do that
and he wrote dot dot dot to destroy the
world and i wrote why
and he said i don't know
they don't give a [ __ ] these hollywood
guys
i thought that they make movies
i i'm not sure if they i'm not sure
what's worse
and i'm not sure if you don't give a
[ __ ] about
i think i have what's worse okay so
there's two things you can do here
you can create the there's a first of
all there's a part in the movie where
godzilla is dying
and they need to revive him and this
alexander skarsgard
guy is like i got it i got the idea and
i'm as a
watcher i'm like whoa he's got the idea
how the [ __ ] are they gonna revive king
kong
he's like i'll fly my plane park it on
his chest and we'll explode it and then
his heart will start beating again
and i go
but that doesn't make sense and he did
it and it happened and it worked
and then there's another part where
godzilla's in the middle of the world
in the middle of the earth all upside
down and also right side up and [ __ ]
and he has to get back to tokyo
what am i even saying this is
actually what happens in the movie
though
and he has to get back to tokyo so
godzilla breathes a [ __ ] hole from
tokyo to the center of the earth and
then
[ __ ] king kong floats through it
and then kills him with an
axe that happened to be in the middle of
the earth
ah
that's real that's a real movie ah
dude what i want to know is here's the
thing
if the people with the franchise are
like who gives a [ __ ] dude we're just
gonna put out this
[ __ ] it's gonna be worldwide
people in japan and asia they don't give
a [ __ ] as long as there's fighting with
big monsters
and they say well what about like people
in america and they say
america's a fraction of what we're going
to make and they'll just watch it anyway
and you too because it's king kong
i respect that get those bags
[ __ ]
get those [ __ ] ass bags okay
but i have a feeling
that it wasn't that i have a feeling
that it was oh
i got it just like alexander skarsgard
in that movie
the exec was like i got it he'll fly the
plane on the chest
and then put it on
king kong's chest explode it and then
king kong's heart will
start beating again and then like the
other guys are like
oh yeah but there's got to be one or two
me's in there that are like
hey but yo about the sense about it
and then they say it's a [ __ ] big
lizard and an ape who gives a [ __ ]
it was such a bad [ __ ] movie and the
thing about that movie was
the only people in that movie were
people
that um
that people that nobody saw that people
like didn't understand
like you've seen them before but we're
like like who jean renau was in 1990
where you were just like who's that
[ __ ] person oh she's from what
the lead in it the [ __ ] alexander
skarsgard who i didn't even know his
name until right now
the guy he's to me is the guy from true
blood which i never saw that
and then there was also the [ __ ] guy
who was the only person i do know their
name is
[ __ ] millie bob thornton and [ __ ]
uh
the [ __ ] her name milly bob thornton
millie millie bobby brown
millie teddy pendergrass why is her
[ __ ] last name bobby brown isn't that
a [ __ ]
millie people bryson
[Laughter]
dude millie peebo bryson dude
wow how much does people bryson get
[ __ ] paid 50 grand to come to
somebody's birthday party and sing
dude hey what's happening guys hi i'm
people bryson
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you it's a happy happy birthday
to people bryson he still says his name
even though it's [ __ ]
mary's birthday doesn't give a [ __ ] and
then he goes happy birthday to you and
he goes
and [ __ ] s and puts out all the
candles with himself
and he goes good day where's my check
and um milly pop pop milly bob
milly bobby brown was in it and uh she
was in it and that was
she's a good actress but why was she in
it and then someone
and then the [ __ ] guy who plays her
dad is the [ __ ] guy from that show
the daily news and also the king kong
guy
um in the other king kong movie
it's so confusing dude and he is a good
actor and he was in blood
what the [ __ ] that movie on show on
netflix blood not blood sport blood in
bloodline bloodline
who's that guy they're all the guys that
are [ __ ] in other movies where you're
like oh yeah oh and the girl from the
[ __ ] town is the lead
who i don't know her name
put [ __ ] tom cruise in it dude
god damn it put [ __ ] harrison
ford in it dude if i'm watching king
kong movie
with godzilla put goddamn matthew
mcconaughey in it dude like that movie
reign of fire with matthew mcconaughey
and christian bale
where they fight dragons that's the
ticket dude
matthew mcconaughey and christian bale
that's the [ __ ] ticket dude they got
uh dragons and [ __ ] in it
i want to see those [ __ ]
swimming swords and axes and one guy
lives underground and one guy
lives overground and one guy's in the
faction and runs it and then that guy
needs the guy underground to help
because he's got the [ __ ] pull with
the people even though the guy above
ground is more strong and
more of a hunter you know what i'm
talking about i wrote it dude
i wrote that right there i just wrote
that right there dude
i could have never wrote as as dumb as
that movie was
i could have never wrote it the king
kong godzilla thing
how do you write [ __ ] like that honestly
like and i don't even mean the the
logistics of it which don't make sense
how do you
write and then the
huge ass big robot godzilla comes to
life
like that's what happened and he
unplugs himself and now dot dot dot he's
got a mind of his
own and that's in bold in the script and
you're supposed to be like
whoa with one fell swoop he breathes
fire into his creator
the student has killed the teacher you
know what i mean this is what they say
and then [ __ ] guy who was cast
because of
because of politics his line
god damn
um it's just like
dude come on man and there's the movies
like that and then there's movies like
nomad land is that the movie with
francis mcdormand
oh yeah cool oh i'll watch that yeah
i'll watch what's it about oh it's about
a lady and that's it all right
yeah dude sign me the [ __ ] up dude one
nine dollar ticket for nomad land what's
it about
a lady roaming around well dude
why didn't you say let me wait in line
for it before the movie theater even
even opens up like they do for star wars
and let me dress as francis mcdormand's
character
because that's amazing dude oh it's
about
a [ __ ] lay dude hey the movie's about
some lady that's what it's about
some lady that's looking for some [ __ ]
but really what she's looking for is
some [ __ ] inside her
right i didn't read about it but right
isn't that what it's about she [ __ ]
probably is in a tent for way too long
in one of the acts or some trailer
why are they making that dude cause you
[ __ ] get tricked and you watch your
[ __ ]
and you see her and she does the i like
king speech style acting
and you're like god damn francis
mcdormand is good and she is good
she's a great [ __ ] actress
put [ __ ] zombies in it put a [ __ ]
goddamn vampire in it
anyway i'm talking about movies too much
but like dude
these [ __ ] movies
al pacino's 5 7 i just found out i
didn't know that i i met him once at
sylvester stallone's house that's a
sentence i just said
i don't know how the [ __ ] dude i don't
know how that happened but i was there
and i [ __ ] i have a pic i'm gonna
send you the picture
uh no you know what i'm gonna [ __ ]
put it up right here there's me and al
pacino
[ __ ] chilling out like two a-listers
dude
i could do that kind of acting oh yeah
um
speaking of movies let's look at this i
found this article that just [ __ ]
was hilarious it's a um
a computer my disc is almost full i
don't give a [ __ ] man it's always almost
full dude
hey do you want to put in the updates
later just
[ __ ] let me do it when i want it's
always like should you do you want to
know in an hour or do you want to know
tonight
do you want to know tomorrow do you want
to know when i [ __ ] i'll just look it
up when i need to do the updates dude
what is it [ __ ] white tiger i gotta
get the [ __ ]
black pangolin or whatever the [ __ ] it's
always some
chartreuse leopard or mac [ __ ] you know
what i mean
hey did you get a chartreuse leopard
it's cool you get to see now
now you get to see if someone
um now i get to see if your friends are
in the and you get to put the text up to
the
this is on a buzzfeed so you know it's
really good
this article is on buzzfeed so you know
it's really good
and it's called 15 tv moments that were
actually kind of
first of all actually kinda should never
be in a [ __ ] title of an article
okay send secure if you're writing it
you better know 15 tv moments that were
actually kind of toxic now that i watch
them again
okay no this is the title for that 15 tv
moments
that actually no 15 tv moments that are
goddamn
[ __ ] shitty now and we shouldn't have
done it but we did
and you can still watch them because
we're not taking them off the air
just because of that
[Laughter]
so this is by lauren girafano which i'm
sure she's a great person i have no
[ __ ] idea
i feel like they pressure these these
[ __ ] blog peop these blogs to come up
with [ __ ]
come on what are you coming up with it's
like the cops at the end of the month
with their tickets
how many tickets to write six wow
[Music]
tom wrote 20 he's gonna be a lieutenant
um looks like you're just gonna be
[ __ ] waving cars by in an
intersection
all good you're not making us money um
we asked the buzzfeed community which tv
moments are low-key toxic that's
whoa there we go
two things two terms i don't like
low-key and toxic toxic is fine when it
means toxic
when it's when you're talking about
poison
or [ __ ] you know that's it actually
or if something's really toxic
but low low key i'm done with it dude
people say low key only when [ __ ] is not
low-key
hello key stabbed him really
yeah what do you mean low-key he's kind
of [ __ ] low-key just walked up to him
and just low-key stabbed them
what the [ __ ] well that's some low-key
was it a man on a woman well that's
low-key toxic
um low-key toxic dude
and uh here we go we asked buzzfeed
community which tv moments were low-key
toxic
and honestly they weren't wrong here's
what they said dude these were the
[ __ ] clips they came up with okay
i'm just there's like 15 i'm gonna read
some of them one on parks and recreation
when anne broke up with andy and instead
of moving out he lived behind her house
in a tent so he could keep an eye on her
and then the chris uh guy
chris uh with a p what is it pratt
chris [ __ ] pratt um says
i just want to be close to her house
because i need to protect her there are
some weird people that live around here
and they think that's toxic because why
would a man have to
protect a woman
okay and it's stalking i guess which by
the way
okay i'll get to this part later
actually on friends when ross lied to
rachel about getting their marriage and
all don't give a [ __ ] i don't care dude
that's
i'm gonna skip that one uh i don't get
this one
um that's not one i want to
read there was a good one i wanted to
read hold on
here's a good one on grey's anatomy when
derek dated nurse rose because he wanted
to make meredith
jealous these [ __ ] names you know
nurse rose and meredith derek
and it's a white guy jesus
who's rose she says he says rose is a
circulating nurse i kissed her once i'm
sure you know that that's why you're
asking me
she says when he says when she says when
did you kiss her
he says yesterday now are we gonna talk
she says so yesterday you were making
out with scrub nurses and today you're
building our
our dream house hey
toxic
he [ __ ] made out with another chick
and to make her jealous
so what the [ __ ] we can't watch grey's
anatomy
look at this six on gilmore girls when
dean cheated on his wife slept with rory
and blamed everyone but himself for
ending his marriage
we're not happy she's not happy and i
can't make her happy it was a mistake
and i know that now
it's over i know we both feel it you and
lindsay yeah me and lindsay
he says it's a mistake
toxic dude uh i still got the [ __ ]
ammo in here by the way i haven't said
it yet that [ __ ] makes this article
nothing
oh how on how i met your mother when ted
lied about being in a love
in love and robert holy [ __ ]
on brooklyn nine-nine when amy demanded
that jake decide on the spot if you want
to have kids with her and even after
never had a conversation once before
they got married
like what is this [ __ ] on the office
when jim made a huge financial decision
decision to buy a house and never
consulted his wife
toxic dude a comedy
this is the office this is the [ __ ]
thing i was holding off on saying these
are
carrick these are characters in a show
it's not toxic these are all character
in a show with a lot of people the guy
bought her a goddamn house and says
i bought it it's ours
dude if somebody bought me a house guess
what i'm doing
rolling around on the floor before the
furniture gets there
i'm a pig in [ __ ]
oh you bought me a house imagine
somebody you bought me a house well
that's toxic
i'll [ __ ] stab someone low-key if
they say that [ __ ] to me dude
look look look look at this a quote half
of jim's antics are pretty toxic and he
definitely
wouldn't be a pleasant person in real
life to ever deal with
you mean the joke guy in the office
you know it would be a real piece of
[ __ ] to have to [ __ ] babysit
pinocchio that guy lies
can't watch that get it off the air
his nose grows
also oh there's more there's one here
with a woman
they're all dudes
uh two here with a woman on look at that
look at how this one starts
uh the first two words i'm just i'm out
on riverdale
toxic that word dude
that [ __ ] word toxic
they got on [ __ ] chris chrissy teigen
because she bullied someone when she was
24.
uh i guess i don't really know i saw
the tweets some of the tweets and it was
courtney stodden that
that that that chick and uh she bullied
other people too i guess and said uh
something like kill yourself or
something
and uh and other stuff like oh you're
an idiot or some [ __ ] i don't know
she lost [ __ ] deals with target
bloomingdale's
uh macy's they were just like
she did what and how do people feel
about that
other pissed dude
it's weird because the this is the worst
part about it they knew that that's
who she was everyone knows chrissy
teigen
takes jabs at everyone online
on twitter they know that when you hire
her then
you know that's who you're hiring hiring
so bloomingdale's macy's and target
can go [ __ ] themselves because here's
the deal you knew who you were hiring
and you bent because somebody brought up
oh but she's a bully
everyone's getting canceled dude
and then i saw [ __ ] people on the
right that was like finally we got
someone good to get canceled and it's
like dude you don't get it man
it's so [ __ ] up they got mad at joe
rogan
today or yesterday for three days ago
whenever you're listening to this about
how he said oh yeah for white
middle-aged
dudes they're trying to put us into
network so we can't ever say anything
and they'll already you know you laugh
now but we'll be silenced i'm
paraphrasing
and they're like [ __ ] joe rogan [ __ ] joe
rogan everyone's like [ __ ] joe rogan
i mean how about the fact that how about
the fact that with some nuance
if you actually listen to what he's
saying with some nuance
he's a little bit right what about that
everyone fit into the mold everyone fit
into the mold if you're out of the mold
[ __ ] you're out no you're shut
people are like why is this guy on tick
tock
can these people stand alone in a room
even is
okay it's weird as [ __ ] get out of it
you don't fit in the mall get out but
guess what dude nobody fits in the mold
nobody fits in the [ __ ] mold the mold
gets smaller and smaller
as you create it it's the only thing
that doesn't [ __ ] get bigger
it's not a house it's not a luxury hotel
it's the mold you're creating
and you're creating it and it's getting
smaller and smaller dude
it's like black guys when they laugh
you get the biggest black dude he starts
laughing
smaller and smaller and smaller until
there's one person in the [ __ ] mold
and he's alone or she's alone
why the [ __ ] do you why do you want to
be alone one person fits in that mold
and it's elon musk
[Music]
it's not he's not elon musk he's already
outside the mold
people wouldn't even [ __ ] be on
saturday night live with him dude
people wouldn't even actors on saturday
night live
this was in the headlines a week ago
actors on saturday night live were like
hey
uh i don't want to act with him in
sketches
and [ __ ] lorne michaels
buckled he's like okay
you don't have to if you don't wanna no
dude you're fired
this is a job dude if you're a [ __ ]
target
since we were on target for a little bit
if you're on if you work at target and
you're like i'm not if
elon musk comes in i'm not gonna [ __ ]
ring him up dude
this guy's anti-vaxx
you go home
these [ __ ] [ __ ] dude what about
real life when you grow up
what about when you grow up i saw a tick
tock someone complaining
crying their eyes out you know what
anxiety is real and if a teacher asks
you to come to the front and you say you
can't maybe listen to
them if you're uncomfortable what about
when you grow up
and the world doesn't cater
you can't say but i don't wanna at the
dmv
you don't get your license you can't say
but i don't wanna
at the [ __ ] any any place
but i don't want to do jury duty
you're fined you're uh you're arrested
or something i don't know
every time i get those [ __ ] things i
don't even open them i throw them out
prove i got it
oh you're summoning me for jury duty
where was it
where is it oh we mailed it to your
house oh
proof i got it i never saw it
i think it got i think you know what i
think it did i knew i was looking
outside of my house and one
time i saw the mailman come in with this
big ass sack
and as he was running up my driveway i
saw one thing
one piece of [ __ ] paper just do that
must have been that
never got it happened seven times
uh you go to the doctor hey you have a
you have [ __ ]
something wrong with your spleen we
gotta do surgery
i don't want to though why my anxiety
daily beloved
i don't want to though
dude when i die
you know how you got to [ __ ] you
gotta get buried like this
or like this [ __ ] all that [ __ ] dude
bury me like this
sexy as [ __ ] for real
with only pants on
with a shirt [ __ ] all that pants on bow
tie
like this and a [ __ ] capri sun right
here with the straw out so i could drink
it in hell
the only guy in hell with a [ __ ]
capri sun just sucking it down while
other dudes are hot as [ __ ]
well you [ __ ] didn't bury yourself
with a pr
capri sun dude what'd you bury yourself
with that [ __ ] stupid tux
i'm chilling i just got pants on and a
bow tie and a capri sun
get over here and [ __ ] me the devil oh i
[ __ ] up
sorry guys i wish i
i wish i could dig instead
[Laughter]
oh i like the boy with the bow tie
come over here and plug me
oh god damn it that capri sun
is mine now
[Laughter]
that capri sun is my that capri sun is
mine now you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that that'd be funny [ __ ] i
don't care
did you just see the [ __ ] i would be
to the guys digging
with the [ __ ] capri sun i can make
hell funny [ __ ] dude i'll make it funny
[ __ ]
put me in hell dude put me in [ __ ]
hell
[Music]
bow tie capri sun just sipping
also uh
also uh [ __ ] um there's no hell
how about that hopefully um
what's this my dad directed what what
show is this
what is it crate cap just say it
oh grey's anatomy yeah i know he knows
i hope he directed that [ __ ] episode
[Laughter]
dude i keep it real just because you're
in my family doesn't mean i can't
[ __ ] keep it real
[Music]
mcsteamy
dreamy
dude
uh mcsteamy and mcdreamy dude
[ __ ] that oh wow [ __ ] one fire just
texted me tom hardy's five nine
knew it see told you i told you babe i
told you dude
one [ __ ] he came through one fire
came through tom hardy's five
nine dude he [ __ ] came
he's trapped zilla i'll give it to him
he's trapped zillow with the [ __ ]
when he played with the dark knight he's
trapped zilla
but dudes five nine i give it to him
he's got it he's a [ __ ] turtle
if you put him on his belly and he moves
slowly you might you might put him in a
lake or a pond
i'd give him that much but the dude's
five nine
he came through with the shortness i'm
telling you
i'll give you that much he looks like
captain america when he's relaxed and
ready to fight
with the [ __ ] shield on his back i'll
give you that much
but the dude doesn't need to duck under
any doorways and yeah sure he's sexy as
[ __ ] but shrunk
hey what's going on i'm tom hardy how
you doing this is my real voice i know i
act with like real cool [ __ ] going on
but this is what you get i'm minnie
what's that oh this this is steel uh
links
wrapped around and then a big steel link
at the bottom because
technically i'm a keychain i can't get
it off
well i'm a [ __ ] idiot yeah no this
you see how there's key
now you see how there's keys in the
bottom there that goes to my car
that's a smart car and then this goes to
my house i live
actually on a um a putting
green uh on a mini golf course so
embarrassing
but it's really i'm i mean i'm you know
i'm a really good actor and i'm sexy on
screen but yeah
so that's i can't get it off it's on my
hip
it's funny because god's funny
wow dude hell yeah i'm 6'2 [ __ ] yeah i'm
a tall drink of water
thanks god
love finding out people are short
i win that battle
christian bell six foot [ __ ] man that
sucks he's good he's tall as [ __ ] saw
him once
some wants sauntering down the street
someone's sauntering the guy's the man
dude
christian bale at the end of the movie
the fighter when he's just all like yeah
you know that's when uh and then starts
to cry that's dry heave acting
that's the kind of [ __ ] that i do dude
that's the kind of [ __ ] that i do
i do dry heave acting
hey what's going on i'm tom hardy how's
it going
oh [ __ ] god i'm mad at that racist
reporter
so there's two things here i got two
[ __ ] things here
this is the fart segment
i got two things about farting now
look this podcast does
not go lowbrow
you know that i'll prove it to you watch
[Music]
previously on congratulations
i tt in my pants a little bit so you
know we're highbrow
okay and you know we never go below that
line
of course um
but farts are a part of life and i've
got two things that have to do with
farting
and i gotta talk about them because you
can't stop me
it's my true nature um
there's two things here
uh one is
uh [ __ ] but oh no that's buzzfeed
oh okay well there's two here look at
the things i title it under guy blasting
a fart
and then well this one is actually the
one i should do first guy blasting a
fart
this was posted by [ __ ] jerry which
everyone gets mad at [ __ ] jerry for like
stealing content i don't give a [ __ ]
like this is stuff on the line they're
memes
i don't care they took my meme once or
twice who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
my boyfriend met my parents this weekend
he tried to hide a fart outside he ended
up alerting our doorbell camera
wow that's that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
of this dude
let's play it can you throw it in there
was that a [ __ ] bee close to your ear
oh he let it out silent he let up more
oh he's waving behind his ass bro what
is the guy's [ __ ] in his this is like
30. he should he should know that
doesn't work
dude the two farts are awesome how he
waited the second fart out and then he
waves it and [ __ ]
like pulls his he was he met his parents
[ __ ] that dude boyfriend met my parents
this weekend i tried to hide a fart
outside god now he's got it on tape he
farted and tried to air it out outside
on the deck by the way you bring it back
in
you have to stay when you fart you got
to stay where you are
for like three minutes that fart will
follow you man
i do farts and then i walk into another
room and kristen's like
hey what the [ __ ] and i'm like what did
you fart and i go
dude not for a while you gotta you gotta
wait
you gotta wait the fart out you gotta
it's like
imagine it treat it like [ __ ]
okay wait it out chill the guy went
right back in so they smelled it anyway
but they got alerted on the doorbell
which is hilarious
he went back in and the whole family was
like this
do you need toilet paper if that
happened if i saw my friend today when
he walked in i would be
[ __ ] laughing in his face out of love
but dude he did that and then that's so
[ __ ] up
don't do that dude when i meet my girl's
parents i make it a point to blast
ass as quickly as i [ __ ] possibly can
and loud dude
[Music]
what you don't do it that's actually i
have a buddy
who has a girlfriend and he's had a
girlfriend now for like five months
and he's like dude i haven't farted in
front of her yet and i'm like
what you got to do that that's so sexy
it's not sexy to fart it's not sexy to
fart in front of
your girl but it is so sexy
to do it and then be like what now
i carry the [ __ ] this sound board
with me
when i fart and i [ __ ]
i straight up just [ __ ] what
why is it not working no it's not
working [ __ ] it i go
it's not working i clicked it again yeah
good
doesn't work my whole computer's frozen
yes dude i
love what a [ __ ] macbook pro freezes
it shouldn't
it cost eleven hundred dollars and it's
frozen yes
dude wow but never [ __ ] it's doing
all sorts of [ __ ] this is great
this is great it's doing all sorts of
[ __ ] like it's trying to [ __ ] cure
hiv great great great talking about hiv
too much in this podcast yes all right
great
sorry you know what whatever dude
but yeah that's the sexiest thing you
could possibly do is fart and own them
unbelievable dude are you kidding me
everything is [ __ ] against me man
renner came in with the [ __ ] hell nah
i ain't forgot
guy [ __ ] blast ass on the porch dude
don't blast ass on the porch unless
you're on the porch already don't glance
dance on the porch and let you around
the porch already
don't go outside to fart man fart inside
fart under the covers
with your significant other i do it all
the time man
and she goes like this chris and i say
what
every time every single time i pretend
like i don't know i say
what she says did you fart and i say a
while ago
and i just [ __ ] did it
and i say maybe one of the dogs that
that one may be one of the dogs because
i farted [ __ ] a while ago
and i just [ __ ] did it
she's a rabbit too she could smell him
before they come out sometimes i'm like
are you
in my [ __ ] sometimes she's like did
you fart and i'm like
[Music]
it's like memento this [ __ ] goes
backwards how's she do that
is she [ __ ] whatever the guy's name
is in mental i don't know anybody's name
anymore
guy pierce guy pierce well in my defense
don't be
have your name be guy that's like having
your name be person
that's ridiculous dude guy how lazy are
your goddamn parents what should we name
him
a guy
it was between guy and dude just drunk
as [ __ ]
drunk australians is the toying guy and
dad
in there she wanted uh something like
[ __ ] gay right like henry or
something and i was just like
ah the fellas at the mill are not gonna
like that
so i told them yeah gotta be [ __ ]
gaia dude
i didn't even try person i knew she
wouldn't [ __ ] go for that and she's
like well [ __ ] roll the dice
sweetheart
guy we came up with [ __ ] guy can't
believe she wanted [ __ ] thaddeus
i must [ __ ] divorce to right there
[ __ ] guy pierce
if my parents named me guy and i grew up
and then had a brain
i would be [ __ ]
i'd fart all over him i'd fart all over
him dude i'd pin him down and [ __ ]
fart all over them
i'd eat so much pasta and [ __ ] four
hours later i'd drive over
to their house and i'd fart all over
them why would you listen to npr when
you can listen to this dude
so that guy blasted a fart and wasn't
sexy about it should have been sexy
about it and stayed
in the pocket in the living room and
farted and looked her father
in the eyes
[Laughter]
hi i'm the person dating your daughter
where's your bathroom
now here's another one this is the still
the fart segment
we're almost done here but this was on
the daily star
and this [ __ ] killed me man i mean it's
kind of [ __ ] i hope the guy's okay
daily star instagram james argh arjun
okay so just
like don't just say james arjun you know
like you don't need to put the [ __ ]
nickname
if it's half the [ __ ] last name it's
already
it's has revealed that he has been
vomiting blood and
this thing by the way [ __ ] takes off
immediately
has like just the sixth word is vomiting
blood
it's like a plane in gi joe because
those used to take off like this
like most reporters will write the
[ __ ] caption and it'll just slowly be
a [ __ ] take-up
this [ __ ] was on it was one of the cobra
in [ __ ] joe this [ __ ] just took off
james arjun has revealed that's why they
put
in there so vomiting would still be
pushed back a little bit further the
editor was like we gotta [ __ ] make
this vomiting came too soon and they
were like
i can give him a nickname he's like i'll
allow it
what's the rest of it well he's been
vomiting blood and can't fart following
his life-saving gastric and
whoa whoa whoa the guy can't
fart front page
look at this james arg arjun apparently
this guy's a star
let's hope god damn it let's hope it's
not just some poor guy in a hospital in
england
that is like oh so turns out i can
[ __ ] fart
get alert the media
get them here
james argent can't fight who's that who
gives this [ __ ] the guy's got an
[ __ ]
i swear to god it's like a [ __ ] what
is it what is he
what is his [ __ ] how is it not a fart
we tried to do everything i swear to god
we gave him [ __ ] peppers we gave him
cheese we gave him cheese for four days
that's all he ate was cheese and milk
he's not farting where the hell is it
going
yes mate he's vomiting up blood
where the [ __ ] are the reporters you
guys are letting them do this for four
days
and you haven't alerted the [ __ ]
daily start
jesus christ you know give him a
nickname
james so [ __ ] the only way the essex
star has
the 10 pound 10 000 pound emergency
surgery i don't know what that is that's
probably [ __ ] 900 million dollars
to help him lose weight okay so that's
what happened the only way is essex
the only way is essex star has
oh maybe that's the show the only way is
essex star i don't [ __ ] know had the
ten thousand pound emergency surgery
to help him lose weight having
alarmingly piled on the pounds okay fine
sure
first of all work out but also okay if
you're gonna get that [ __ ] lap band
surgery or whatever
or do at least get the [ __ ] thing
that like the old-timey guys were they
would rub their belly on a treadmill and
they
wouldn't even have to do anything and
the 33-year-old troubled tv personality
now hopes oh he's troubled so look i
don't know this guy so don't get on me
for [ __ ] making fun of somebody if
he's troubled all right
now hopes he can get his life back on
track after his latest health scare
wishing you a speedy recovery arge
image credit and then it literally says
image credit
instagram what kind of [ __ ] backward
[ __ ] is the daily star
dude the worst part about it
is the picture of the [ __ ]
thing is of this guy just
holding his tummy smiling looking in the
camera going like this
i can't fart
but they gave me cheese and jalapenos
for four days
can't fart
i got a surgery to [ __ ] help me lose
weight and then also
can't fart vomiting not blood
jesus christ look at these comments
what a [ __ ] melt that is so funny to
me
what a melt what a [ __ ] mouth
he is a tuna melt that's what british
people will say dude
um
all right we're down here what a [ __ ]
melt
and then someone says get well soon hope
you can fart soon no nobody said that
that'd be amazing i'm gonna comment that
look at this good for you james just
remember
it is just a tool and you still have to
follow the guidelines good luck
hun what is this person
insane good for you james just remember
it is just a tool and you still have to
follow the guidelines
good luck hun hashtag
life saving gastric bypass that's what
it says
sorry but i laughed it he can't fart i
looked at the pic on the post and heard
him saying
wow let's look at more
how do i get more comments this is
annoying when you look at it
gastric band operations are banned in
many countries for good reasons
see proof raw air i should get this
removed isip
let's see more
look at this one wait oh i just missed
do you tell anorexic people to just eat
more
i don't even understand how that makes
sense somebody tagged someone else and
said what exciting news
wow dude
oh wow this is the most british one ever
alarmingly put on white
is it alarming if you tiff your face
full of calories 10 for a short cut
that's
[ __ ] him up bit of willpower and being
healthy job done
what do we arrange those words in a
sentence
look at this if this dude british people
if this [ __ ] even makes the paper
it's saint george's day
i do it
to many whoppers getting famous for
being [ __ ] idiots
if you like your grub fair enough enjoy
it don't look for sympathy when you're
feeling sorry for yourself being a
[ __ ]
end of the day you're boring whoppers
oh my god dude are you [ __ ] me
somebody just commented fat elvis
oh my god
look at this these people just get it
why was it emergency surgery he's lost
weight before he just needs to do the
same again
surgery is not a quick fix it will still
need to address the issues surrounding
his food addiction
otherwise the surgery is pointless
dude make friends in the [ __ ] comment
section
these [ __ ] are trying to meet
people in the comments section i think
you need to have a bit of respect for
someone who's had major surgery
i a fan of anyone from dowie but i
do feel anthony empathy for someone
battling addiction and weight problems
arch you got this
dude he did the punch emoji yeah dude
if addiction's addiction if you got a
[ __ ]
deal with it you got to deal with it
props for you props to you
[ __ ] arch you [ __ ] that this
picture yeah i can't fault and i'm
vomiting blood or something star
that's the level of confidence that this
other guy who tried to air his [ __ ]
fart out
there's all sorts of people in the world
does the guy who won't fart in front of
your dad or mom
and goes out on the patio and tries to
[ __ ] fart
and then there's orange dudes who was
like i'm gonna eat whatever i want
whenever i want i'm gonna get real fat
i'm gonna make doctors fix it and if
they [ __ ] it up
i won't be able to fart i'll vomit blood
up
and when they take the picture of me
i'll be chasing one eye
in a hospital gown down
don't know i'll put a day on the end of
it um all right dude that's it
wow what a fun episode uh you guys are
great thank you so much for listening
and um go pick up that merch man uh
there's still a f
there's still some left on the uh on the
new life rips dude they're dope
can't wait till mine comes in i'm gonna
wear them all together like i'm on the
team like i'm a [ __ ] avenger of life
like i'm not i'm the life rips avenger
hey guys that's the episode
uh on youtube if you want to see the
long extended cut
go sign up for our patreon it's all on
patreon uh it's
uh at patreon.comcrystalia and it was a
[ __ ] good one man we had fun
uh and by we i mean me also you get uh
extra behind-the-scenes footage and you
also get
one episode extra a month that
people on youtube don't get so thanks
for listening and go hit that patreon
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
i like bury me with a capri sun though
that's funny but whatever the world
blanche